what do you love most about Joe Rogan oh
that dude
I could go on and on about Joe Rogan Joe
Rogan is the most selfless individual
I've ever met he doesn't care if he has
you on the podcast he wants you to be
the funniest person in the room he wants
you to be the smartest person in the
room let me tell you something Joe Rogan
is 10 times smarter and funnier than me
he wants you to shine he wants you he
wants to put you over to his fans he
that [__] did not exist before he
started doing his podcast people didn't
share you with their fans no one was
like Hey man come on on the road with me
they brought you on the road because
they wanted you to suck and they put you
in bad scenarios Joe Rogan wanted you to
shine he gave he gave so many people
beautiful gave them careers gave them
Joe could have looked at his podcast as
his thing this is my thing I bring on
these guys I'm gonna be the funniest guy
in the [__] room I know some guys
that have done that
might be me might be I might talk over
people not listen really well Joe had
did the opposite now look I've tried to
learn from Joe on my podcast and do the
same that guy when you think about it
you name 10 of his friends I bet eight
of them are doing Arenas right now
they're all doing theaters all his
friends do theaters all his friends do
theaters he's he is just
you know I I he and he won't accept this
compliment I tried paying it to him uh
in
in Austin when I was in Austin last well
he's not good at accepting compliments I
gave him a gift too and I said hey I
need I need to show you I can't just
tell you this because it's going to fall
in deaf ears I need to give you a minute
so you have something so you know that I
think about you and I'm grateful for
having you in my life a lot for many
reasons I have more friends in my life
because of you he taught me how to trust
people again I have a career because if
you have a major motion picture because
of you I do Arenas because of you
without you in my life a lot of these
these things maybe never would have
happened I never would have told the
machine on stage I wouldn't have gotten
I would have never started a podcast I
wouldn't have three podcasts like I mean
all these things are are things he not
just he didn't just take me to the water
one time and give me a drink he he gave
me a machete and he said this is how I
get to the water you gotta put your own
path but just give me a heads up you can
also use my path whenever you want I
mean he he is the most selfless
individual he will go down in history as
one of the 10 most important people in
stand-up comedy without a doubt he
changed the game it didn't exist like
this before him and uh and he won't
accept that compliment well it's a gift
you give him I can't tell you is it a
dildo there's a dildo double-sided dildo
I go hey when you get free time can we
scissor [__] each other